[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin Ihnen allen einen schönen
guten Abend Christin otto hat später
Wintersport und auch ein bisschen mehr
wir wagen uns aufs Eis guten Abend dann
blicken wir gemeinsam auf die
Themen Haushaltsloch hin um Frage tief
her in stürmischen Zeiten gibt sich die
SPD auf ihrem Parteitag zuversichtlich
und bestätigt die Spitze Klingbeil
esken Warnung vor verheerenden Folgen
während Israel weiter den gazaastreifen
bombardiert debattieren die UN über
einen sofortigen
Waffenstillstand Eis Kunst und ein prima
Lauf mit nur kleinen Wacklern in der Kü
gewinnen Minerva Hase und Nikita volodin
das Grand Prix Finale und feiern damit
ihren bisher größten
Erfolg die Gesellschaft für deutsche
Sprache hat das Wort des Jahres gekürt
es heißt krisenmodus und steht
sinnbildlich auch für die Situation der
SPD beim Parteitag haben die
Sozialdemokraten ihre Führung zwar
jubelnd bestätigt aber Sie müssen auch
eine Vertrauenskrise managen nur noch
jeder siebte würde sie aktuell wählen
hinzu kommen Krieg Inflation und
Haushaltsloch die es ebenfalls zu
managen gilt und gerade auch vom
Haushalt wird abhängen wie geschlossen
die SPD im krisenmodus ist lass Bohag
von Krisenstimmung bei der SPD ist am
Tag 1 ihres Parteitags wenig bis nichts
zu spüren der Kanzler kriegt lang
anhaltenden Applaus die
Parteivorsitzenden gute Ergebnisse und
das zu einer Zeit in der die SPD laut
Umfragen viel Vertrauen bei den wähln
verspielt hat die Erwartungen an die
eigene Parteispitze aber sind groß
gerade mit zwei sich immer wieder
streiten Partnern in der Ampel müssen
wir schauen hier auf dem Parteitag klare
Positionen zu finden und auch dann in
die Breite und die Bevölkerung zu
kommunizieren damit wieder klar wird
wofür 100% SPD steht meine
Erwartungshaltung ist dass wir klare
Zeichen setzen was wir wollen als
Sozialdemokratie z.B keine Kürzung im
Sozialbereich z.B einen höheren
Mindestlohn und diese Zeichen müssen
jetzt raus auch an die Koalitionspartner
die SPD will wieder ihr soziales Profil
Stärken fordert Änderungen bei der
Einkommens und Erbschaftssteuer mit
Blick auf die Haushaltskrise soll die
Schuldenbremse zwar nicht abgeschafft
aber reformiert werden
die Schuldenbremse ist ein
wohlstandsrisiko geworden und deswegen
müssen wir sie verändern deswegen müssen
wir sie neu gestalten und dafür sorgen
dass mehr Investitionen in diesem Land
möglich werden Forderungen aus der Union
wegen der Haushaltskrise das Bürgergeld
zu kürzen lehnt die SPD klar ab CDU und
CSU hetzen im Chor mit der AFD gegen die
Ampel mit dieser März CDU haben wir
wahrhaftig die populistisch der
Opposition aller Zeiten morgen spricht
Olaf Scholz zur Partei erwartet wird
eine Rede die nicht nach Kanzler klingt
sondern nach Genosse ich würde mir
wünschen dass Olaf mal wieder den den
Kampfgeist rausholt der in ihm steckt
und den wir auch in der Bundestagswahl
und den Wahlkampf bei ihm gesehen haben
weil der ist da aber das muss jetzt auch
mal die Menschen da draußen erreichen
die Genossen feiern auf ihrem Parteitag
viel SPD pur ein Akt der
Selbstvergewisserung da scheint es auch
erstmal egal ob und wie ihrer
Forderungen tatsächlich in
Regierungshandeln umgesetzt
werden Matthias fornhof ist in Berlin
mit dabei Matthias die SPD bietet
bislang ein Bild der Harmonie wie
stimmig ist das angesichts der
schlechten
Zustimmungswerte na ja diese tatsächlich
auffällige Harmonie ist wohl auch ein
Reflex auf die vielen Krisen und
Probleme das Letzte was die SPD jetzt
brauchen könnte das ist die Logik
dahinter wäre Streit in den eigenen
Reihen mit Blick auf W nierlagen und das
anhaltende Umfragetief wird hier fast
schon trotzig daran erinnert dass die
Partei schon mal im Umfragetief war und
dann doch die Bundestagswahl vor zwei
Jahren gewonnen hat ob sich das
wiederholen lässt weiß allerdings heute
niemand das Führungspersonal wird hier
demonstrativ gestärkt mit sehr guten
Wahlergebnissen für die Vorsitzenden
Saskia esken und Lars klingbei sowie
Generalsekretär Kevin küert auch der
betont freundliche Beifall für Kanzler
Olaf Scholz passt da ins Bild Stabilität
Geschlossenheit das soll die Botschaft
sein Matthias einiges haben wir schon
gehört welche Erwartungen haben die
Delegierten an eine Einigung in der
Haushaltskrise womit ist da zu
rechnen na ja sozialen karlschlag will
die SPD unbedingt verhindern es geht ihr
sehr ums eigene Profil mehr als darum
kompromissangebote an die ampelpartner
zu machen um die fehlenden Milliarden
für den Haushalt zu finden so sollen
reiche steuerlich mehr zur Kasse gebeten
werden getreu dem Motto wer viel hat
kann auch viel geben die Schuldenbremse
will die SPD anpassen sprich lockern all
das ist leicht hier zu beschließen und
es ist schwierig Regierungspolitik draus
zu machen vor allem gegen den erklärten
Widerstand der FDP am Ende werden sich
alle bewegen müssen davon aber ist auf
diesem Parteitag bisher nichts zu sehen
vielen Dank nach Berlin Matthias vornof
ja die wiedergewählte SPD Vorsitzende
Saskia esken später im heute journal
Interview zu sehen ab 2
Uhr und alles rund um den Parteitag in
Berlin finden Sie jederzeit online bei
ZDF heute und in unserer
App es sind noch 3 Stunden Bahnstreik
dann haben sie zumindest das Gröbste für
dieses Jahr überstanden das war's dann
aber auch schon mit den guten
Nachrichten für Pendler und Bahnreisende
völlig klar ist nämlich auch dass der
Ausstand an einem reisefreudigen
Adventswochenende für viele ziemlich
unangenehm und frustrierend war und ist
Stefan er
berichtet viele Gleise verweist nur
vereinzeltfahren Züge im Frankfurter
Hauptbahnhof rund 80% der
Fernverbindungen finden heute nicht
statt im Nahverkehr läuft es regional
sehr unterschiedlich Bahnfahren wird zum
Glücksspiel und zur
Geduldsprobe wir konnten aber alles über
das Deutsche Bahn App andere Zügel
Regeln so ja ging eigentlich alles ganz
gut bis jetzt wir finden da benutzt ein
Mensch seine Machtposition auf zum
Lasten der Verbraucher stinkt uns extrem
die Bahn und der angesprochene gdlchef
wieselski haben bisher kaum miteinander
verhandelt und solange die
Arbeitgeberseite nicht bereit sei über
den Knackpunkt der Arbeitszeitverkürzung
zu sprechen werde es keine Fortschritte
geben heißt es von der GDL und deswegen
sind wir im Warnstreik und wenn die
Abstimmung am 19 Dezember ausgezählt ist
werden wir dann nach dem 7 Januar mit
längeren und auf heftigeren
Arbeitskampfmaßnahmen reagieren kritik
gibt es vom Fahrgastverband zwar sei das
Streikrecht ein hohes Gut und der
lockführerberuf müsse attraktiver werden
allerdings sehen wir das sehr kritisch
dass der Streik jetzt 24 Stunden vorher
nur angekündigt wird da können sich die
Fahrgäste gar nicht darauf einstellen
wir erwarten eigentlich dass der Streik
mindestens 48 Stunden vorher angekündigt
wird nach dem Warnstreik will die Bahn
schnell wieder zum Normalbetrieb
übergehen wir setzen alles daran dass
zum Betriebsbeginn am Samstag früh
wieder alles fährt im Güterverkehr wird
es länger dauern die Staus aufzulösen
die sich gebildet haben aber im
Personenverkehr hoffen wir dass wir alle
Reisen wieder morgen ans Ziel bringen
können allerdings dürften viele Fernzüge
sehr voll
werden die humanitäre Situation für die
palästinensische Zivilbevölkerung wird
immer schwieriger es gibt kaum noch
Nahrung und Wasser Israels Militär will
offenbar Fakten schaffen und hat seine
Angriffe vor allem im südlichen
Gasastreifen nochmals ausgeweitet
innerhalb von 24 Stunden wurden knapp
450 Ziel angegriffen Michaele
berichtet heftige Explosionen im Süden
von Gaza Israels Armee forsert den
Vormarsch um hananjunis die Hamas soll
zerschlagen werden bevor der
internationale Druck für einen
Waffenstillstand zu groß wird das
Militär veröffentlicht ein Video das
hamaskämpfer zeigen soll der Häuser und
Straßenkampf wird auch im Norden
erbittert
geführt offenbar macht Israel dabei
immer mehr Gefangene wie diese Aufnahmen
in sozialen Medien belegen sollen warum
die Männer halbnackt festgesetzt und in
demütigender Weise zur Schau gestellt
werden beantwortet die Armee auf
Nachfrage nicht ein Regierungssprecher
erklärt wir reden über Männer im
kampffähigen Alter die sich in Gebieten
aufhielten in denen Zivilisten seit
Wochen evakuiert sein sollten jetzt
befragen wir Sie um herauszufinden wer
tatsächlich Hamas Terrorist ist und wer
nicht währenddessen wird die Versorgung
Lage für die Zivilbevölkerung in Gaza
immer schwieriger seit wieder Aufnahme
der Kämpfe kommen nur noch wenige
Hilfslieferungen an es gibt so wenig zu
essen worauf warten sie vielleicht dass
wir langsam sterben sollen wir etwa vor
Hunger sterben gestern Abend begann in
telaviv hanuka das jüdische Lichterfest
Angehörige der Geiseln zünden Kerzen an
eine für jede der 139 Menschen die noch
immer in Gaza gefangen gehalten werden
mit dem Krieg in naost beschäftigt sich
auch der Weltsicherheitsrat der
Vereinten Nationen in New York er
debattiert zur Stunde über eine
Resolution die von den Vereinigten
Arabischen Emiraten eingebracht wurde
sie fordern einen sofortigen humanitären
Waffenstillstand die USA der wichtigste
Verbündete Israels im un-serheitsrat
haben ihr Veto
angekündigt wir wollen Nachfragen bei
Elm Ton in Washington Elm die Abstimmung
zur
waffenstillstandsresolution wurde
verschoben warum und welche Rolle
spielen die
USA ja der USA Vertreter hat im
Sicherheitsrat folgendermaßen begründet
er hat gesagt selbst wenn Israel die
Waffen niederlegen würde hätte die Hamas
weiter die Geiseln und würde auch ihre
Angriffe auf Israel weiter fortsetzen
deswegen unterstützen die USA keinen
Waffenstillstand sondern nur eine
weitere humanitäre Pause um den Menschen
doch zu helfen und genau das will heute
Nachmittag hier in Washington State
Department hinter uns US Außenminister
blinken seinen Gästen vermittelt
vermitteln er hat den saudischen
Außenminister zu Besuch mehrere
Vertreter von arabischen Ländern und
auch den türkischen Außenminister hier
in Washington die beiden Administration
steht innenpolitisch unter einem
riesigen Druck sie will auf keinen Fall
die Wähler im Land vergrätzen die Israel
eher unterstützen indem sie
möglicherweise tatsächlich die
Unterstützung für Israel reduzieren
könnten und gleichzeitig wollen sie
natürlich auch die arabischen Amerikaner
von denen viele immer Unterstützer der
Demokratischen Partei waren ebenfalls
nicht vergretzen deswegen arbeitet man
hier heute Nachmittag auch an einem
Friedensplan der Palästinensern auch
eine Perspektive möglichst schnell gibt
aber die Zeit läuft ab der UN
Generalsekretär hat vorhin sehr sehr
klar gemacht dass die zivile Ordnung im
Gazastreifen kurz vor dem totalen
Zusammenbruch steht Elma vielen Dank für
die Einordnung nach
Washington in Krisenzeiten leiden die Kl
Ambitionen weltweit das zeigt der
klimaschutzindex der Umweltorganisation
German watch sowie dem new climate
Institute erstmals wird im Bereich
Klimapolitik kein einziges Land mit gut
bewertet deshalb bleiben die ersten drei
Plätze des Rankings leer auf Platz 4
kommt Dänemark Deutschland hat sich um
zwei Plätze verbessert auf Rang 14 nach
Einschätzung der Umweltorganisation tut
keines der 90 Länder genug um den
Temperaturanstieg auf 1,5° zu
Grenzen erst Thüringen und SachsenAnhalt
jetzt folgt Sachsen die AFD wird künftig
auch im Freistaat als gesichert
rechtsextremistisch eingestuft das
erklärte der landesverfassungsschutz in
der Summe sei klar dass parteiunktionäre
und Mandatsträger verfassungsfeindliche
Ziele verfolgten die AFD wies die
Entscheidung als politisch motiviert
zurück ein 18-Jähriger Muslim der einen
Geschichtslehrer tötet und enthauptet
weil der angeblich den Propheten
Mohammed beleidigt hatte der Fall Samuel
parti erschütterte vor d Jahren ganz
Frankreich der Täter wurde von der
Polizei erschossen aber gegen sechs
Jugendliche die ihen unterstützt haben
sollen wird noch heute das Urteil
erwartet und die Angst vor weiteren
Attacken radikaler Angreifer ist groß
aus Paris Anne
Arend sie hätten ihren Lehrer Samuel
parti warnen können stattdessen haben
sie ihn ausgeliefert an einen
islamistischen Attentäter fünf jungen
mussten sich wegen Bildung einer
kriminellen Vereinigung vor Gericht
verantworten Verleumdung lautete die
Anklage gegen ein
Mädchen sicher ist ohne die Denunzierung
durch die minderjährige die hinter
dieser ganzen Intrige steckt hätte es
keine Aufmerksamkeit in den medialen
Netzwerken gegeben und somit auch kein
Verbrechen das ist die bittere
Logik der Prozess fällt in eine Zeit in
der die Sorge vor einem Anschlag und die
Nervosität in Frankreich groß sind wie
bei dem Attentat vergangenen Samstag
unweit des Eifelturms sind es zwar
Einzeltäter die töten oft jedoch
angetrieben durch Hetze im
Netz es gab schon immer Radikalisierung
aber jetzt passiert sie extrem schnell
innerhalb weniger Monate wandelt sich
die Person und das ist umso weniger
kontrollierbar und so prägt das Thema
Sicherheit inzwischen die politische
Debatte vor allem mit Blick auf die
Olympischen Spiele im kommenden
Jahr wir werden in Paris und in allen
Städten in denen die Spiele stattfinden
Absperrungen einrichten um
Personenkontrollen durchzuführen in
einem Land das nicht nur die größte
jüdische Gemeinde Europas beherbergt
sondern vor allem auch die meisten
Muslime ist seit dem Gazakrieg die
Terrorgefahr noch weiter
gestiegen jetzt schauen wir nach
Südamerika und auf einen Grenzstreit der
sich offenbar zuspitzt es gibt immer
größere Spannung zwischen Venezuela und
dessen Nachbarland Guyana Venezuela
beansprucht die esquibo Region die zu
Guyana gehört dort gibt es mehr Öl als
in kuvit und Erdgas mehrere
südamerikanische Länder riefen jetzt zu
Verhandlungen und einer friedlichen
Beilegung des Konflikts auf Christoph
röckerat es wirkt wie aus der Zeit
gefallen ein südamerikanischer
Staatschef präsentiert eine Karte auf
der er sich den Großteil seines
Nachbarlands einverleibt Venezuelas
autoritärherrschender Präsident Maduro
provoziert das ist das Gesetz zur
Schaffung des Bundesstaats Guyana se
Kibo aufgrund der Entscheidung vom
Sonntag am letzten Sonntag hatte Maduro
die Bürger dazu aufgerufen der Annektion
zuzustimmen völkerrechtlich hat die
Abstimmung keine Bedeutung doch im
Nachbarland Guyana sind sie beunruhigt
die Region
ekibo umfasst zwei Drittel des
Staatsgebiets und verfügt über riesige
Erdölvorkommen der Präsident Guyanas ist
empör
wir werden nicht zulassen dass durch
diese verzweifelte Drohung unser
Staatsgebiet verletzt oder die
Entwicklung unseres Landes behindert
wird Venezuelas Ansprüche auf ekibo
reichen zurück in die Kolonialzeit doch
maduros Motive dürften andere sein
kürzlich wurden weitere Ölvorkommen
entdeckt und im nächsten Jahr wird
gewählt in
Venezuela das ganze ist ein
Ablenkungsmanöver sagt ein ehemaliger
Botschafter Venezuelas der uns aus
Karakas zugeschaltet ist
es geht Maduro darum Patriotismus zu
schüren und die Opposition als
Vaterlandsverräter
darzustellen ein Angriff Venezuelas ist
unwahrscheinlich die natürliche Grenze
gilt als unpassierbar die Truppen
müssten durch brasilianisches
Territorium marschieren dennoch wird
sich der unserheitsrat mit der Krise
befassen und Brasilien hat eine
Verstärkung seiner Truppen an der Grenze
angeordnet so jetzt zum Sport und einem
deutschen traumpim Eiskunstlauf chrtin
da passt richtig was gut zusammen
bereits zum dritten Mal in dieser Saison
entscheiden die Paarläufer Minerva Hase
und Nikita volodin eine Konkurrenz für
sich diesmal beim Grand Prix Finale in
Peking eine Konstanz die Hoffnungen
weckt und an glorreiche Zeiten
erinnert zauberhaft und beeindruckend
erst seit einem Jahr trainiert das
Berliner paar Minerva Hase und Nikita
volodin zusammen und schon gelingt Ihnen
der erste deutsche Sieg beim Grand Prix
Finale in Peking seit 2017 seit aljonas
ein Jahr später wurden sie Olympiasieger
wir sind ein sehr junges Paar wir haben
noch viel vor uns und ich glaube wir
haben noch sehr sehr viel zu bieten für
die Zukunft sie zeigten eine gute aber
nicht fehlerfreie Kühe in Peking ein
Sturz beim dreifach Wurf ritberger
konnte Hase knapp verhindern dennoch
Gold im Paarlauf für das neue deutsche
traumpa Hase
volodin vier Spiele vier Siege
Deutschlands Handballerinnen sind ganz
nah dran an ihrem Minimalziel
Viertelfinale bei der Weltmeister in
Skandinavien nach dem
2422 gegen Rumänien reicht bereits ein
weiterer Erfolg in den restlichen zwei
Partien der Hauptrunde gegen Serbien und
Dänemark um im Turnier zu
bleiben das Internationale Olympische
Komitee mit Präsident thomas Bach
erlaubt Sportlerinnen und Sportlern aus
Russland und belaruss an den Olympischen
Sommerspielen 24 in Paris teilzunehmen
unter neutraler Flagge und strengen
Auflagen anders als bei ihren letzten
Olympia Auftritten sollen Sportler aus
Russland und Belarus strickte
Neutralität waren außerdem muss nach den
Vorgaben des IOC nachgewiesen sein dass
die Teilnehmer den Krieg ihrer Länder
nicht aktiv unterstützen und den
antidopingcode einhalten
Militärangehörige sollen ebenso wenig
stberechtigt sein die Mannschaften
beider Länder die Pariser
Bürgermeisterin ann idalg hatte sich
wiederholt gegen eine Teilnahme von
Sportlern aus Russland und belaruss
ausgesprochen deren Mitwirkung in Paris
im nächsten Jahr hat das IOC nun möglich
gemacht und der doosb begrüßt die EOC
Entscheidung es herrsche nun Klarheit
nun denn vielen Dank Christin ja der
Deutsche Wetterdienst der warnt vor
Glatteis in Teilen Bayerns dazu gleich
mehr mit Christa Orben Morgen begrüßt
Sie hier Barbara hallwig schönen Dank
schönen Start ins Wochenende und auf
[Musik]
bald
guten Abend durch die milde Luft die
jetzt zu uns einfließt geht es am
zweiten Adventswochenende dem Schnee an
den Kragen das Tauwetter verschont bis
Dienstag nur die höheren Lagen des
Südostens und auch heute Nacht ist es in
der Westhälfte schon frostfrei in der
Osthälfte setzt sich diese mildere Luft
erst morgen durch da sinken die Werte
noch auf -4° deswegen Schneid es anfangs
noch zwischen der Ostsee und den Alpen
in Teilen Bayern herrscht weiterhin
Glättegefahr durch gefrierenden Regen
bis in die Frühstunden des Samstags und
erst am Vormittag entspannt sich hier
die glätteesituation der Tag startet
insgesamt aber trocken auch wenn der
Himmel oft bewölkt bleibt der Wind im
Westen aus südlichen Richtungen der
frischt aber schon mal auf und von hier
breitet sich dann am Nachmittag ein
kräftiges Regenband bis in die Mitte aus
da können über 10 l regenfallen in
Nordrhein-Westfalen rheinland-fals und
im Saarland im Osten bleibt es bis
abends trocken hier kommen die
Temperaturen aus dem dauerfrostbereich
raus + 2° gibt's in Vorpommern in der
Kölner Bucht erreichen Sie zweistellige
Werte mit + 10° und es wird noch milder
zum Anfang der neuen Woche und das in
Kombination mit starken Regenfällen
sorgt für steigende Hochwassergefahr
Anfang der neuen Woche in Süddeutschland
tschüss